salut à tous nous sommes au royal times
muséum au canada le plus grand musée
consacré exclusivement à la
paléontologie des vertébrés et notamment
aux dinosaures est alors la
particularité du royal tyrrell museum
c'est qu'il est localisé en plein milieu
du gisement dhr à des gisements dans
lesquels on découvre les dinosaures et
là je vous emmène sur le point de vue
par où on va découvrir les badlands dans
lesquels on découvre ces fameux
dinosaures ont créé badlands c'est ce
que vous voyez derrière moi ici en ce
sont des sols argileux de belle couche
bien définis quasiment horizontal et à
l'intérieur desquelles des plus beaux
dinosaures les plus beaux squelettes de
dinosaures du crétacé ont été découverts
donc ici on est dans l'alberta et à des
dinosaures les plus fameux de l'alberta
ils portent ils portent les noms locaux
c'est-à-dire albertosaurus gorgon au
russe et de montreux n'ya donc tout un
tas de choses que vous devez
certainement connaître je peux souffler
parce que ya pas mal de marche
donc là on va découvrir le point de vue
sur les balles de lens
[Musique]
regardez ça ce sont les badlands le
muséum et en bas lorsqu'il ya d'assez
impressionnant c'est que la ville juste
à côté
toute son économie absolument toute son
économie est basée sur la présence du
musée le musée a été construit à peu
près dans les années 80 et c'est
impressionnant parce que leur traversant
la ville il ya des statuts de dinosaures
absolument partout dont une d'un t-rex
ce qui fait à peu près huit mètres de
haut qui est assez impressionnant et
très moche d'oeil très peu réaliste on
va dire pour pas faire de jugement de
valeur mais assez c'est assez
impressionnant en fait tous les ya des
tas de chopes de shopping
avec des dinosaures en emblème des
statuts absolument partout il y avait
même une reproduction d'un squelette de
spinosaure à un moment très très beau
très beau coin
[Musique]
on voit là juste à côté du musée dans
les badlands mon ami david vient de
trouver un petit marché de pouvoir
fossiles
on en voit encore par terre en place le
morceau qui est blanc à l'intérieur de
la roche mars et un morceau de bois
fossile
donc on royal aux parieurs on peut par
contre n'a pas loin de les ramasser
comme burgel les fossiles sont mieux
quand ils sont à leur place et puis
après si vous êtes vraiment très très
chanceux gars vous pouvez trouver des
pros d'arbres entier pour soumia c'est
pas nous qui l'avons trouvé évidemment
il s'agit en fait d'un morceau de
séquoias vieux de 72 millions d'années
et qui donc date de la période du
crétacé
cet arbre mesdames et messieurs a connu
les dinosaures banques et les gens on
s'est suffisamment amusé dans les bacs
lundi pour aujourd'hui
maintenant il est temps d'aller voir le
muséum
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a mis nos amis vous présente la pièce
de résistance se connaître
[Musique]
de tyrannosaure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous vous rappelez le philosophe qui a
fait la une des journaux il n'y a pas
très longtemps parce qu'il était
complètement préservée avec la peau
et tous les tissus mous autour
eh bien le voilà
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
un peu de finesse des détails
moi sur la surface
[Musique]
la dcri village de notre visite c'est
qu'on peut voir le labo de préparation
ce qui fait qu on est de l'autre côté de
la vitre par rapport aux visiteurs
habituels théropodes juvénile en cours
de préparation
hélas le squelette complet
d'un add rose or extrêmement
impressionnante
c'est
bassin dans qu'il ose on s'engueule
notre squelette complet
je
qui semble appartenir aussi ana droz a
donc
preuve en tout cas que c'est un
herbivore par les extrémités des griffes
des soins à rosny à ce que va nous dire
nos 37 noter que l'apéritif la cour
commence les trucs drôles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
centre aux orres juste ici
km
le rayonnage
sur impressionnante
pas là
féminines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'est tout concept et dureau
j'espère quelques
après n'avait pas préparé à une telle
collection du possible
donc voilà si vous avez
l'occasion de venir n'hésitez pas c'est
que du bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]